hi guys so great to see so many hustlers
okay so I'm super excited to be here and
typically when I go to conferences I
really appreciate speakers who can share
real stories and also I'll give some
technical things that I can get started
on right away so hopefully I will be
able to do both of those for you today
so let's start by talking a little bit
about myself so you know who you're
listening to I moved to the US when I
was in high school from Korea so I heard
from Sam that today there are
representations from five continents in
the audience which is pretty cool
hopefully there's some representations
from Korea my background is in business
I went to business school and I've
always been in the consumer products
industry
I love absolutely love working on
products that I know will end up in
hands of customers especially if it's
something that they can engage with on a
daily basis like coffee meets bagel so
today I'm here to tell you and talk a
little bit about my story and how I
started a tech company without a
technical co-founder and the short
advice is if you can get one go get one
because it'll make your life a lot
easier but you know not everybody has
that option I didn't have one and it
certainly should not stop anyone from
starting or at least getting started so
I want to talk first about the story
behind coffee meets bagel how and why I
got started and how I built my first
Minimum Viable Product without any
technical knowledge and then finally how
I found my CTO so when you talk to
anyone about dating in general not just
even online dating you probably never
find anyone who
was like hundred percent satisfied with
the dating scene there's always some
problem and some complaint and that's
because dating is really hard you know
getting two people to fall in love is is
a big challenge for me online dating in
particular had three main problems one
it's optimized for men so if you look at
what I mean by that is if you look at
vast majority of online dating products
it's optimized for surfacing as many
photos as possible and then really enjoy
browsing photos of women like they
genuinely enjoy that you know it's not a
bad thing right and most products that
are out there are designed by men but on
the other hand women don't particularly
enjoy browsing through endless photos of
men yeah in fact you know I think more
often than not we enjoy browsing photos
of other woman than men so so that's a
big problem obviously not only that
women get harassed often you know you
put a picture up that has any like
remote resemblance to woman's face or
woman's body I guess it won't take you
long before you you start getting like
creepy messages from creepy people and
then finally online dating is a chore
let's face it right like you don't ever
run into anyone who's so excited like I
can't wait to try this online dating
platform like looking so forward to it
no it's still something that people kind
of just do it because you know okay I
kind of should meet somebody it's hard
to meet somebody because I'm so busy
let's just give this a try so how do you
make this more exciting how do you bring
exciting back to dating because it
should be a very it's an exciting thing
right meeting somebody for the first
time and how do we deliver on traits
that focuses on quality safety and
simplicity which are traits that are
especially important to women so
our solution to this was curating one
match a day every day at noon and giving
our customers something to look forward
to creating that magical moment on a
daily basis that's how you bring
excitement so we do we curate the
matches and we use variety of
information mainly a coffee meets bagel
it's very important that we actually
make matches through your friend network
so somebody close to your network which
also creates environment and the sense
of safety so now that I have this ideal
but no one to help me build this like
how did I go about it when I first
started this sort of journey the first
advice and the best advice I got was
this is from a friend so I've lured out
the name but it says this guy looks
pretty good
good work experience school a is
definitely not as well ranked as school
B but it's fine I feel you don't
necessarily need a super good guy as
there is nothing very hard technically
about this concept if you get traction
then you can hire great people as they
will want to come and work for you but
for now you can save your cash I feel
it's more important that you validate
the concept fast and for that you need
someone who can work full-time to get a
prototype out fast so for my first
engineer I didn't look for Stanford MIT
grad I I just wanted somebody who had
who was capable of building something
very simple my Minimum Viable Product
and who was available I mean lots of
people are busy doing lots of things and
my MVP consisted of four things one it
was going to be simple Facebook app to
get information from Facebook account
because I knew the product for this
product was getting access to the social
graph was very important second thing it
had to have basic functionality where
you can see a profile and like or pass
and then basic admin tools for me to
actually create these matress and
finally we needed an ability for people
to an animal
is unanimously chat an anonymous phone
number so that if there's a mutual like
they can actually talk to each other and
so it's pretty I mean it's not that
simple I mean there's still some
complicated elements here but it's
enough for me to actually prove out
variety of hypothesis I had like are
people willing to give me Facebook
access are people going to be chatting
people willing to give me phone number
and are they going to be chatting etc so
these are some designs initial designs
like Sam mentioned my co-founders are my
sisters and one of them is a designer so
I had that area covered so these are
some initial designs I had on this you
know a lot of things were imported
through Facebook is profile where you
can set up preferences and then pictures
I'm it's not the most sophisticated
designs where you can input phone number
and then finally where you can like or
pass if you take a look at this you can
already tell there's a lot more in in
terms of features here then the MVP that
I stated so this is very common mistake
that lots of people make and that I made
also and we ended up whittling down a
lot of things you really want to stick
to the bare minimum things that you need
and I think it's very easy to feel like
oh my god I really need that feature
when in reality you don't really need it
and I see now a lot of companies they
use Google Forms or even surveys without
even building anything to get started so
that's something definitely important to
remember so once that I had concept my
first developer I hired from oDesk I had
a friend who was a Python engineer who
told me about oDesk and recommended that
I use Python because I guess that's what
it was familiar with and he liked I
don't think there was any particular
reason and he also was the one who you
know suggested that I create a github
account so whoever I hit whoever I hire
can actually sum a ton checking code so
I chose Python and
a ton of responses from oDesk that's
what happens if you put anything on on
on that platform
and so it was really hard for me to tell
who was better like just even looking at
ratings and reviews so I needed
something additional to be able to
evaluate so I started with a small
project I actually gave project to them
it was very simple and I asked three
questions how long do you need to
implement this what questions would you
ask me to clarify the project and can
you answer my question in the dock I had
some questions and I was super surprised
that the variety of answers I got I made
varied from like two hours to 40 hours
no questions to like a lot of questions
etc and this really gave me good
insights even though I don't I can't
fully vet out them technically but it
really gave me a good insight into how
experienced they were and so this is an
initial posting that I used it says
expert Python Django engineer for
website with Facebook integration needed
and if you see the posting I mean I
explained I introduced the team a little
bit it looks like a real job you know
job posting right this is how you also
attract better candidates even on oDesk
and this is a the initial project that I
gave it was a one-page basically ask
them to hit create something an app
where you can log in with Facebook
collect specific information and then
have a sign-up page and I didn't provide
any mock-ups and there are some parts
that are left purposely vague because I
wanted to see if this is a type of
person if there's ambiguity are they
going to bring it up to me and discuss
okay hey this is not very clear let's
clarify this or is this a type of person
who's going to just kind of go off and
make assumptions and everything and then
two weeks later come back with something
I you know didn't really expect and so
this was a very good exercise and I was
able to hire an engineer from Indonesia
who I paid $15 an hour
and I think for the MVP it took him
about working about four weeks and he
dedicated about 15 hours a week so not
bad right so once I had the MVP I had 50
of my friends actually sign up and their
friends two single friends and sign up
and actually test this obviously just
singles and I was the one who was
curating match every day during the
matchmaker thing and at noon I was you
know the one who was manually sending
emails I was using MailChimp and I
tested this for a week and the result
was very positive
you know vast majority of the users were
logging in every day and I also after a
week followed up with most of the users
by phone to get some qualitative
feedback and it was very positive and
and the overall response was you know
they really looked forward to getting
the email at noontime click-through was
very high so I would call that a success
right so I was ready to get this you
know MVP into a full-blown product and
then something terrible happened to me I
lost touch with my engineer and he
disappeared out of the earth so I had
this code that I didn't understand and I
couldn't get in touch with him and so
that leads me to my final section how I
found my CTO so the problem with oDesk
it's not lack of talent there are a lot
of great developers it's lack of
commitment and consistency a lot of
these contractors work for multiple
clients at a time so if something
happens with one project they may not
have you know all that time to dedicate
to your project and I was paying this
person on an hourly basis so there's no
repercussion if he just you know takes
off and leaves and so I would suggest in
terms of incentive structure some
combination of hourly as well as a lump
sum payment upon delivery of the project
I don't think it's a good idea to just
do it on project basis because one you
may not attract the best people out
there and to I think if you know the
engineer ends up under estimating the
hours which they often do they may end
up cutting corners you know because they
don't want to put a lot more hours to it
so some combination is what I would
recommend but you know regardless I
needed to find a local developer my CTO
and the key to finding CTO is I mean I
guess there is no shortcut here it's
basically using your resource to go
after every channel possible I mean I
went after meetups Craigslist friends
coolest people are often surprised when
I tell them I found my first University
oh through Craigslist but you know there
are it's still very effective channel I
found my second one through meetup list
I sent out a middle of the email to Oh
meetup Python meet up in New York and
that's how I found my second one but it
took a while I mean this kind of
conversation takes time obviously the
timing has to work out so I think for my
second CTO I start a conversation with
him in July and then we didn't end up
working together until January so keep
those conversations going this is the
the Craigslist posting that I had you
know fell in love with Python great
Python and Django developer needed a new
online dating company full-time or
part-time with potential CTO opportunity
notice I didn't advertise specifically
for a CTO position because I didn't want
to set that expectation it was very
important for me to first work with this
person together and then together coming
to a decision is this CTO position the
right job for for you and then this is
my email to the New York Python meetup
group advice needed where is the best
place to find a Python programmer and
this is where I got the response but now
you have a you know somebody that you'd
like to work with but how do you hire
them when you have no money because I
didn't I hadn't raised any money at that
point and typical market rate in New
York at the time was you know if you
want to hire any good enough engineer
you have to pay
upwards of $100 hundred to maybe hundred
fifty dollars an hour so this is what I
suggested I'm going to pay you $30 an
hour and you can bill me every two weeks
I'll pay that we'll work together for
six months and if we mutually decided
this is the right job for you then we'll
talk about equity compensation and then
if we doesn't work out then I'll pay you
the difference a few months later we
said October at the time and the
discussion happened in January and my
thought was okay there's still a risk if
things don't work out I would have to
pay you for that amount but if things
work out I would have raised at least
some money by then so it bought me some
time and I could conserve my cash one
thing I want to say about generally CTOs
is I I've ran into so many CEOs who are
working on really early-stage products
that obviously they came on board but
six months to a year later they're not
happy because they feel like they didn't
get compensated fairly in terms of
equity because founders share versus the
situation is oftentimes very different
the difference is really wide and if you
think about it if you brought somebody
pre-funding and they have to go through
justice must uncertainty and risk as you
do you think of put yourself in their
situation and think like what is the
fair amount that that they'll want so
that they don't have to worry about this
kind of stuff and actually dedicate to
work right because the last thing you
want to do is get somebody on board
because that takes time and then a year
later they're resentful and then they
are thinking of leaving and so I think
oftentimes like investors investors will
tell you okay this is the fair amount or
you might read something on TechCrunch
or whatever this is very month but I
think you should personally think about
what you think is fair to give out to
your CTO but you know at the end of the
day it may still not work out so my two
CEOs initially it didn't work out with
them provide a variety of reasons you
know personality or whatever location
didn't work out so the last message I
want to give you is you need to take
your time before committing to each
other
I was lucky my third one we met actually
through a recruiter by that time I had
raised some money so I could actually
work with a recruiter and then it was a
great match so now you know it's been
amazing but I made those two mistakes
and it was great that I didn't commit
anything yet right
so with that summary of my talk one you
don't always need an a player to get
things started don't wait for that
genius was going to come in and solve
all your tech problems because they
don't exist get it out there build it
and iterate get a tech advisor and this
doesn't have to be anyone official in
any sense right I talked about my friend
all they need is to spend maybe five to
ten minutes a month they don't even have
to meet you in person and you can you
know just shoot them an email take five
minutes like hey what do you think about
this resume or do you think this code
snippet is clean it's not much time for
them but it's very valuable for you
again there is no shortcut you have to
work at it and it takes time and one way
to to help with that is being creative
even now I love recruiting outside of
the valley because the valid things are
just so competitive and people aren't as
willing to take risk with someone you
know who may not have although you know
hot startups in their resume etc it
takes more risk and more time to get out
there and recruit so it's less
competitive so be creative and then
finally take your time before committing
it's very important thank you very much
for your time I hope it was helpful
thank thanks Aaron if you have any
questions for please come up yes I was
wondering how do you deal with computer
security throughout the entire ordeal
the possibility of someone hacking into
the site when you're in development yet
to be honest that was not in my mind you
just got lucky essentially yes okay I
guess hey thanks for your time Yul is
very down to earth I love it
you know thank you acting on question
for you is coming in with no money and
you have all these potential CTOs how do
you enter into your legal agreements to
protect yourself with without having to
spend money like with a legal company
and all that yeah that's a really good
question the way I did it which may or
may not be the right thing to do is we
actually wrote something down just very
casually using our own words no lawyer
involved that stated some of these core
things that we operate on and I think by
that point if you need already if you
need a lawyer I don't think that's the
right person because yeah I understand
you need to protect the downside but
when you're that early and you're trying
to be scrappy somebody who's asking for
a lawyer and a contract etc I don't
necessarily think it's the right fit so
it honestly didn't occur to me and
didn't occur to him and I think anyone
who's willing to try out at a start-up
like that early shouldn't want to
involve a lawyer thank you
yeah all right so thanks for sharing
your story it's pretty pretty awesome to
hear I really love to get a little more
detail on that getting that first CTO
yeah $30 an hour seem so cheap the race
you pay like on codementor io or like
easily $100 an hour for a really great
engineer yeah so I imagine the equity
incentive has to really be strong or at
least the I mean I don't know what the
contract you actually inked out with
this guy
yeah gts-r but to get a CTO full-time
like of anyone of any talent in the
United States for $30 an hour I imagine
you must have a really strong equity
incentive if it worked out yeah so um to
be clear when I actually drafted this
contract we didn't have like okay your
equity sure is going to be this
percentage yeah and I think there's pros
and cons to having that conversations
early versus later yeah um all early
obviously gives you clarity but I think
when you have that conversation early
and then this is this is sort of how
like six months later people feel a
little bit resentful or something
because I feel like I'm pulling more
weight and so we need to reopen this
conversation etc note for me um
basically I was willing to give founder
level equity it wasn't it wasn't going
to be equal split but it was very
significant yeah and I typically like to
share this like anyone who asked about
this I think at the beginning if you
want to really attract the right talent
you need to be generous with your equity
but you can't be stingy about it because
this is a person who's going to dedicate
just as much time and energy with you
and try to ride all the roller coaster
ride with you so even now my current CTO
I mean he's almost a COO your fourth
co-founder to me in terms of commitment
and every in every sense um and so I
never felt like oh my god I'm giving up
too much yeah any other learnings here
so I a lot of people say you know
co-founder should be within your network
or you know should be a technical person
that you know so I think hiring somebody
from Craigslist or know whatnot seems a
little daunting yes you just have no
relationship with this person yeah so
random yeah um so any other learners you
can share like if you know you have to
go that route um you know anything else
you kind of learned along the way yeah
so what I would like things that I
didn't do that I would do now is
definitely reference tracks um I find
that really funny here like sometimes if
I ask for references or like Oh
project or something because I guess the
market is so competitive people like my
recruiter would tell me oh you know if
you do that you may turn off some people
and they may not want to apply or
whatever but if you don't even want to
go through that like I mean forget it
then right so I think reference tracks
are really writing even now for every
employee that I bring I take that very
seriously I even do reference tracks
before I bring anyone on site and it's
not just like formal ok I'm just doing
this to check off the box I really drill
down to it because that is one of the
most important data point you can get
about the person I've turned down a lot
of actually opportunities where we
almost you know people were like excited
about this person and then because of
reference we didn't end up hiring ok
yeah awesome thank you thank you okay
we're gonna take these three hey Erin
thanks for the talk so mine I'm running
a really early-stage startup and looking
for a CTO if anyone in the crowd is
interested come talk to me it was crappy
so my MVP is a little bit more
complicated and what I'm looking for in
a CTO is not just someone who's a
developer but also someone I can bounce
ideas off of and really learn and you
know design the product along with them
so when you initially said you found a
CT or developer in Indonesia is that
even possible and do you suggest waiting
to find someone like that over here
where you can have that real time
conversation rather than find someone
internationally and then you have the
time delays and you're not able to have
that that depth of thought yeah I mean
the Indonesia person I wouldn't call him
my CTO he was a contractor that I was
working with I would challenge your
thought about whether your MVPs really
needs to be more complicated because
it's really hard exercise I think you
have to go through over and over and
over and every time you go through that
exercise you'll find something that you
can simplify and so yes it's important
to get a technical co-founder I mean
technical partner who can you can bounce
of ideas
all that stuff and typically like all
the engineers that I've met who want to
join a start-up are people like that you
know they don't want to be just coding
right they want to get their ideas heard
they're very product savvy also so I
think you'll have no problem finding
that person you know here who will you
will be able to talk about product as
well as coding etc yeah I would say it's
going to be a little hard harder to do
that finding that person abroad like you
know thorough desk or something but that
shouldn't stop you again from getting
started it's always much easier to
attract the right partner if you already
have something to show them right so
consider that some mod investment that
you're actually doing in order to hire
better people yeah great thank you thank
you I'm guys once again look out for me
thank you for the talk yeah you had
mentioned that other online dating
platforms were not as great um what
other apps or products did you use as
mental models when you start it out I
mean I tried I mean I've tried
everything and I'm still use everything
right OkCupid match.com all the mobile
labs I think at the time there was like
at the pool there are so many that come
in and out all the time that I can't
even get like keep track to be honest
but I use even now I use tinder
everything to get product inspirations
just to see what other competitors are
doing does that answer your question
yeah I guess it's just in addition to
online dating site ah okay oh yeah yeah
so I actually use now I used a lot of
games gaming products for inspiration
because our business model is also very
similar to that of mobile games and I
absolutely love how a lot of mobile game
products are able to really class
service customers while they provide
personalized services and really
incentivize the users to engage
consistently
with the app so I usually get a lot of
good ideas from just playing games yeah
thanks for the talking
Oh what what range do you consider
founder level equity is one five percent
15 I'm curious like 20 percent well so
if you were to start a company today
with three people I would think you
would split it thirty three thirty like
one-third one-third one-third right and
so if this person is joining maybe it's
not one-third I'm depending also again
where the stage is it but maybe it's 15
maybe it's 20 I'm if it's really early
whatever right so it's definitely I
think five percent to go I hear five
percent a lot I think that's too low if
your post funding that's a different
story so when I say founder level just
really think about okay if I were had
started this company with this person
from the very beginning what would the
equity split head look like I think that
should give you a good guidance and you
were able to raise funding without the
co-founder and without the CTO
so when I raise money my initial fund
seed we raise $600,000 I had the second
CTO but we were still on this hourly
structure we hadn't had like clear okay
you're going to come in as a CTO after I
raise money we had conversations you
were still working maybe a few months
and then we decided okay this is not a
good fit for both of us yeah so then my
current CTO came on board after the seed
round fun okay I got it thanks great
thank you thank you guys